сільського з подільськими машинами far more
олександра мірошника вже майже 40 руки
йому вин керуючи близько 100 гектарів
землі накиди вбито криво з таку миску
дітьми накласти раніше до грибних
аграрії його машини часто ламаються і
вимагаю tippmann ту краще та там зате
кредит банк залишаю нових що кредит
брати ап20 35 20 відсотків речник сюжет
і для навантаження плюс я павичі
гаранту та заставу пит кредити несемо
видобуваєш у татар кратному розвалювати
суми кредиту які майся воротар не
зближуються на фінансовий склад ніжки
богачук українських підприємств німецька
вирубних та сільського з подільських машин
такі
група abba херш розглядатиме україну та
акваль ми перспективний ринок корж
продав манув його руку за мною великих
машин на двадцять миль uni у євро
клієнти фермерство і управляє адже
тисяч до 20 тисяч якось рип ван ян ви
стоїте нову техніку з будки можна
їх розрізати від вікна на нову не рацію та
можна розділити на 1000 уже
і приховували дотеру як папку в
мало деформовані я витрачаю вникають у
харчуванні та фінансування харчування
економічніше харчування 3-х логічніше
українській заповзятливо надають пориву
виймайте com сільського з подільською
машинам я cutie with horse місяць
розпушуючи землю і водночас пейджем lee
min доброго ми знову тури мою у улові
стю грунті для фарма олександра кози
нюка і керує розташовану тисячу ж
віктори зі їдальнею вирішували нам про
купили а скільки в центральній Україні
на сліді кліматичних змін випадаючи
деталі менше душі
з переміщенням центральні регіони д
раніше у нас було цілитися 100 разів уже
більше дасть apple кліматичні мовляв і
через церкви може його ціни нижчі і
стрибки шанси та перспективи розшук la la
навпаки вони тобто ми сьогодні моєму
проти ти над технологію заощадження в
улові
європейський інвестиційний банк виділив
кориди 400-ми червні в євро для
фінансування аграрної кут узи а
найкращим і адже ми янукович грибні
фермер Олександр мірошник pitbull &
компаніям засвоївши 59 руки калашнікова.
спинок підшивається в дружина старим а ви
вкладіть у бургу навіки кашу кредити
стануть дійшли